POST.
IT DID NOT GET OVER THE LINE,
YES,S, FROZE OR NOT. BY
CORNER TRYING TO SLAP IT OUT,
AND THEY DO.
THIS IS ZADINA DOWN THE LEFT
O
END, DAN.
HE UP FOR
BUFFALO.
TRYING POWER PLAY.
NOT MUCH.
HERE'S A
KYLE OKPOSO.
SENDS IT BACK TO THOMPSON,
SCORES!
[ HORN BLOWING ] HIM TO THE
NET.
WHAT A PLAY BY SKINNENEO NET.
GETS A GOOD ONE.
HERE'S A CHANCE TO
GET THEMSELVES SET.
THEY'RE ATTACKING WITH A TONHIN.
THERE'S NO AVAILABILITY TO GET
IT THROUGH TO THE NET.
>> Dan: CAGGIULA TO THEAKES A SN
THE PUCK, SCORES, SIDE OF THE
RUOTSALAINEN, NO, HE POWERS HIS
WAY TH NOT OUT.
DeKEYSER CAN'T GET IT DEEP.
EPS .
THAT BACKHAND PASS BY
RAYMOND.
ACROSS, SCORES, QUICK  REALLY G
SABRES RUNNING AROUND A LITTLE
BI RAYMOND.
BERTUZZI GET A SHOT BY ONE.
SHOT,
BACK THROUGH, AND WITH SOME GOO.
RAYMOND.
HERE'S BERTUZZI TO
LEFT IN OVERTIME, AND HERE WE
GO.
RASMUSSEN.
DAHLIN WITHH